I think this is a really important time for us to revisit the crunchy to
all right pipeline
and I made this video like
a year ago talking about how the super far right and the super crunchy have this
like place of meeting
you're seeing it with the people who are really
really excited about like deregulation
about RFK's commitment to like
redoing the food system because there is a very specific type of like
crunchy Mama loves Jesus
doesn't believe in shoes drinks raw milk but votes red type of crunchy parent is
a lot of these crunchy views are based in the distrust of the government
and they're based in the idea of like
health and purity antitox
whatever you wanna call it
although in small doses those things are healthy and good for you
reading labels making sure you have like
an 80 20 diet checking the sources of your meats
looking into the food industry as something that I did as like
a very niche hyperfixation
but it can lead you to a place of not trusting medical professionals
it can lead you to a place of not trusting the government in general
and that can lead you down
a place to believing somebody who tells you that everyone's lying
I'm the one that you can believe
and when you look at purity
when you become obsessed with purity
you are on a slippery slope to eugenics
you can also see this kind of popping up in this like
pro birther movement where these people who are like no
I'm wealthy and have really good genetics
I should have more children
all stems from the same place
and in a weird dichotomy these like
people who seem like super duper hippies are gonna be won over by the right
because where the right is interested in the purity of society
which already has its own negative implications
these super crunchy people who are on this like
crunchy Mama mode are worried about like
personal health impurity and it's not a far leap
like it's not a far jump
those are those are little islands on the same
on the same wavelength you might start with buying half a cow
and getting a doterra essential oils packet
but you may end up an anti vax
pro fascist government supporter
not everyone
but it's there